And the answer here is that the approximation factor is 2.38, so it's performing worse
than that take two algorithm, which have an approximation factor of 2.
So what that means is that the greedy algorithm, although the strategy might sound good,
doesn't perform as well as the take 2 algorithm, which is guaranteed to have
an approximation factor of 2 and that's why it's so important to prove properties of algorithms
and not just saying--well, this is a sound strategy, this one sounds good,
because while it may sound good, it can actually in some cases perform really bad.
So does this mean that the greedy algorithm is useless and we should always use
and we should always use the take 2 algorithm.
Well, not really because actually for most instances that you would encounter in a real world setting,
so for example a telecommunications networks as Alice is trying to do--
this algorithm here will perform very well, but it is not guaranteed to perform very well.